[Music]  take me  [Applause]  [Music]  Erika Jayne has been serving up sexy  numbers all season long on Dancing with  the Stars which apparently isn't sitting  well with everyone  oh come on are you kidding me but like  her single says here's Erica on Ellen  Monday I don't think so but I think that  we as women are held to leviticus  standards oh yeah men alright so so so  you're not gonna stop being too sexy  well I think you should stop being  yourself at all right though you know  I'm Erika Jayne in the barroom and there  you go well I think it's more confident  and tanks a little bit sexy you know  when it's confidence with sexy those two  things scare people I think a woman yeah  no I know I'm not being facetious I  think that that's true